[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
I also recently watch your video where
you broke down Moana
and it was important to me because that
in that movie they didn't really say
what Island it was like it's barely just
a Polynesian mix and I spent time in
Samoa New Zealand and Tonga and just
fell in love with their culture and also
I've seen as you pointed to and that it
seems like we're getting to a point
where we're being told that the
characteristics of mail are bad that
they've gotten to us to a certain point
but things are getting toxic and we sort
of need women to take over and I'm
seeing it so when I was living in
Brampton just for example we had in our
shopping mall it's full of these poster
saying like who says that that women
can't rule the world and I can see it in
commercials where it seems like the male
is this fool and the man has to take
over and make the decision so I wanted
to make videos like I said about this at
first but now I'm trying to see it do
you think maybe it's it's as if we were
pushed so far towards this Pedro's
culture that they're trying to push it
back so far the other way so that we
sort of end up in the middle somewhere
um I don't know I don't I the difficulty
is that
and I think the difficulty is the
problem of the the problem the big
question right now is the question of
the feminine like to me that's the big
big question is that it seems that
although we talk about feminism and we
talk about you know and we have this
idea that women can rule the world or
whatever but there it seems like that
what's really being damaged in this
story is is the feminine itself that is
the feminine has an extreme has a very
important part to play and a very you
know all these images of like of the
secret these images of the of
potentiality the image of the private
image of you know all these these
powerful parts of society you know are
being you know kind of cast aside so
it's like you're not you wouldn't be
surprised that in a world where where
for example we have this idea that women
can do whatever men can do like that
that somehow is a value that at the same
time our private lives would be be be
shrinking shrinking shrinking shrinking
until you know there is no private
sphere anymore because that's the sphere
like that's like the beautiful sphere of
the of the feminine is this notion of
the of this this this of the home of the
of the of the like of the secret and of
the the the private life um and so to me
that's what that's what's kind of sad
you know that's what's kind of sad in
this and even in like you know first of
all I think it's important to know like
I really do believe that there is no
there is no such thing as matriarchy
like it's never existed and it's a it's
a modern myth like there were just it's
like there there's there matrilineal
societies but matrilineal is not the
same as matriarchal you know Jews are
matrilineal like it's like it there
there's all kinds of societies that
let's say calculate family through the
through the female and there are
societies where let's say there's a
chief and there's like a group of women
who kind of hold his power let's say but
that's still not matriarchy right that's
still exactly this image of like of like
let's say a masculine
this public masculine figure and then
underneath let's say kind of in the in
the background are this group of women
who who kind of hold the power in uh in
a more subtle way let's say and that's
always been how it is like forever like
you know I wrote an article about about
about women and Christianity recently
and I just showed that women women
precede men in Christianity
systematically and so it's like you know
Constantine's mother converts then
Constantine Augustine's mother converts
then Augustine then it's like the the
Prince of the Vladimir's mother and
Russia converts then Vladimir so I get
constantly the women have this like kind
of like a private this private
approaching of the sacred and then we
did in the story it doesn't tell you but
you can see it if you look at the story
then the public little version comes out
where their son or their husband will
convert but it's the women who kind of
secretly go there first you know in a in
a kind of mysterious hidden way it's
like that's beautiful thing like that's
an awesome thing it's like I wish that
we had more of those amazing feminine
characters you know that's why in the
video I showed uh Galadriel in Lord of
the Rings I felt like she was really
like a very powerful feminine figure
where she looks into your eyes and she
like goes right to the bottom of your
soul and she can like see all your
secrets and you can barely look at her
because you know that she's like you
know that there's nothing that she she
she she is the mistress of the secrets
let's say like she can she can see
everything in your deepest desire so
it's like everybody's afraid of her
because of that it's like that's a
really powerful feminine character but
you know the like that this the the
woman who who just is constantly trying
to prove that you can be everything a
man is it's like I mean I I don't even
I'm not even denying that that's
possible it just seems like we're losing
the feminine you know it's just
something very powerful about that
so in moaña it's like Moana they kind of
have the the wise Crone they still have
the grandma
kind of acts as this wise Crone kind of
guides her and follows her so they kind
of preserved that but then Moana is
definitely like a masculine character in
terms of how she acts like that scene
where she's like she like goes into the
pirates and she's like beating everybody
up and she comes back like swinging down
on like the the rope and she hits more
she hits mo and he falls over it's like
my goodness you know can you be more
obvious about what you're trying to do
it reminds me of like how you're saying
about certain cultures where women are
sort of on the inside making the changes
but on the outside we see the men I
think that was in my Big Fat Greek
Wedding
yeah where they have to show that
they're manipulating the man into him
thinking it's it's his own decision and
also I've seen that in Polynesian
culture where it's it's so much more
clear to see there that it's a
hierarchical culture where you you have
to do what the chief says that the chief
worth the chief's word is final and I
think that's part of why I enjoyed it so
much there and feel drawn to go back
there is that you just I feel that my
role was more defined here we're growing
up in Canada where where things are
changing and we're being told that it's
negative for a male to be masculine and
it's positive for a female to be
masculine we're there it just seemed
that okay here's what men do
here's what women do but the women still
with within a family will make the
decisions on the inside but then on the
outside it appears that the man is
through the chief and now we're at this
time were there's so many different
categories that emerging and all the
transgender issues that are coming up
there they've had it for thousands of
years that it's not the quite the same
now but say a family if you have eight
eight children they're all boys if your
ninth child comes out a Boyd the family
would say okay let's just raise this one
as a girl because we need someone to do
these these are chores the chores and it
just it's so completely accepted there
that if
I said more so now it's if a man it
feels that he's homosexual he'll just
dress as a woman and be completely
treated as a woman if that they're
called [ __ ] lady if a [ __ ] lady goes
with a man if they have relations that
that man wouldn't even be considered gay
that but because the other the [ __ ]
lady is completely considered a woman
we're here it seems like we're there's
so many just arguments between between
categories were in other cultures where
they've been doing it for longer and
also I've seen it in Hinduism that many
of their gods are transgendered or or
don't have gender where I feel for me
like growing up Catholic it seems that
our God is very much a male God and just
by the symbol and symbolism we use and
our culture being founded on that
there's it seems that there's people who
have take up such an issue with it like
no that's that's not that's not a man
you're a woman if you don't have you you
are what your genitalia is and it's just
there's how do us the people in the
middle who warrant so much
either way that how do we mediate
between these sides and try to move
forward with this well like I talked
about st. Maximus the Confessor
quite a bit in my talks like I I he's
the he's the the basis of the idea of
logos like even for Jordan Jordan
doesn't necessarily know but he gets his
idea of logos from Solzhenitsyn and from
Dostoyevsky but they take it from say
Maximus the Confessor and say Maximus
had this idea that there were three
genders like there's male there's female
and there's the key called at the
extreme and the end the extreme is
basically all the exceptions and so all
the exceptions would be just put in that
category of exception though so the
eunuchs you know any anybody who's a
eunuch for whatever reason would be in
that exception and then also the monks
actually so the monks were viewed as
being neither male nor female because
they weren't engaging in in in sexual
activity and so the thing that I've been
kind of trying to promote is this idea
of leaving
leaving a category buffer of chaos just
leaving a buffer of chaos at the edge
you know where there are exceptions with
those exceptions the difficulty that we
have now is also because of our
scientific thinking like you know like
our Occam's razor everything has to fit
exactly no there needs to be categories
for everything and so that's what's
being cut becoming problematic with the
transgender question is that it's like
at the edge of something there is a kind
of chaos and there is a kind of let's
say a spectrum let's say like they say
you know but that spectrum has to be on
the edge you know because or else what's
gonna happen is it's going in turn in
our society for sure what's going to
happen is if you try to normalize it the
way that we normalize male/female it's
going to start to eat at the categories
and so you know that's why for example
now you know they're trying to pass laws
where you're removing you know the
father and mother from the law because
you have to account for the exception
it's like you should just leave the
exception and just not talk about it
like not not talk about it in the sense
that it's like a taboo but just like
leave it for the private sphere like
leave it for and and anyway so that's
kind of like my that's what I've been
kind of kind of talking about and but I
think it also like in terms of the
feminine I think it really is I I see it
more like as modernity which has a which
is has been kind of hyper-masculine
let's say like the Enlightenment has
been piper masculine whereas you know in
the medieval world you really had the
importance of the mother of God was was
was great like she really had a very
high importance and there was a kind of
weird balance where for example the
hyper masculine version of Christianity
would have a very high devotion to the
mother of God and so you know like the
Knights like that the Knights who went
on crusade you know they had a very high
devotes and the Templars were highly
devoted to Our Lady and so there was a
more of like a balance between between
the masculine and the feminine let me
tell you I want to tell you one story
about that kind of helps to understand
in terms of Christianity what that can
be in terms of the logos let's say okay
because
there's a story the first miracle that
Christ does okay it's the it's the
changing of water into wine at the
wedding of Cana okay and so that story
you have a situation where okay Christ
is there no one knows who Christ is yet
right only only the woman knows right
only his mother knows who he is it's a
secret okay
now they run out of wine at the wedding
and so
the Mother of God you know Mary goes to
Christ and she says you know they ran
out of wine
and so Christ says like how does he say
this like he says my time has not yet
come
okay it's like what a weird thing to
answer to that question she's saying
there's not enough wine and you're
basically saying I'm not ready to die
yet cuz that's what it means right so
it's like what does that mean it's very
odd and so what it means first of all
the whole idea of changing water into
wine as it is this the idea of taking
chaos and transforming it into something
useful right so it's it's really as
reproducing the act of creation from the
beginning of the world so it's like
she's asking Christ to create the world
basically she's saying show that your
Christ and she's giving him the frame in
which the logos is going to manifest
itself she's saying this is the problem
and now Christ has to answer that
problem that's the feminine the feminine
asks the question right and the man the
masculine answers the question but the
masculine doesn't speak on two unless
there's a question asked of him and so
the feminine gives the frame into which
the logos will manifest itself that's a
very very powerful thing it's like if
you if you think about all the D let's
say the all the repercussions of that
thinking like it's very powerful
it shows how how powerful let's say the
idea of the church who prays who asks
God for something and then God decides
like yes or no or I will you know I'll
answer your prayer but God acts in
answer to the prayer so the church as
feminine frames the actions of God in
the world like it's a pretty powerful
thing if you think about it in those
terms so we just wanted to give you an
idea of like how the feminine let's say
is part of Christianity because that's
one of the criticisms you hear you know
on the on the kind of extreme is that
the Christianity doesn't have a feminine
aspect it's like oh no Christianity
definitely does and and in the
eschatological vision that is in the
whole vision of the whole cosmos let's
say we have this idea of at the end of
time you know the bride joining with the
bridegroom and this idea that like
creation is is united to God and the
feminine is also part in some manner of
divinity like in some participative
manner part of divinity you know and so
you have to kind of see the whole story
all together but it's not the same as
let's say yeah we don't have you don't
have like a we don't have as clearly
like father and mother like the you know
the the father God mother God like it's
not this exactly the same it's more like
an a whole kind of the whole story of
the cosmos brings everything together -
of that of that relationship let's say
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your insights and questions
in the comments section and as you can
please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below